played roulette a little bit and this
dude was just betting
thousands of dollars each roulette there
were like spins that had ten thousand of
his dollars on the board
and he was just like what does it matter
what does it matter you know what does
it matter eh what does it matter you put
this here you put this there it doesn't
matter he puts a five thousand dollar
chip on three
okay
he's got a 1 in 37 chance of turning
this into one hundred and eighty
thousand dollars the thing spinning
right before the dealer says no more
bets the dealer takes the Chip And he
says I don't think you really want to
make that bet do you tosses it off back
to the guy and then the [__] ball
lands on three
okay
so the guy says what the hell did you
take that off for
and the guy says well I didn't think you
really wanted to bet on it and he says
but that's why I'll put it there